زفاف الاميره ايمان ميشيليو تصنع تاريخا
جديدا في الاوسكار حلا شيحه تعود الى
الواجهه والمزيد عن دراما رمضان اليكم
الابرز باسبوع
[موسيقى]
صنعت الممثله الماليزيه
في حفل توزيع جوائز الاوسكار الخامس
والتسعين بكونها اول امراه من اصل اسيوي
تفوز بجائزه اوسكار افضل ممثلات عن فيلم
الخيال العلمي كل شيء كل مكان في نفس
الوقت وقالت يو البالغه من العمر 60 عاما
في خطاب قبول الجائزه بما معناه بجميع
الاولاد والبنات الصغار الذين يشبهونني
تشاهدون الليله مناره للامل والامكانيات
هذا دليل على ان الاحلام تتحقق وتصدر فيلم
كل شيء كل مكان في نفس الوقت لدانيال
ودانيال تشانرت قائمه الفائزين بجوائز
الاوسكار هذا العام حيث حصد سبع جوائز من
اصل 11 ترشيحا وحزل فيلم على جوائز افضل
صوره افضل مخرج افضل ممثله افضل ممثل
مساعد افضل ممثله مساعده افضل سيناريو
اصلي وافضل مونتاج وذهبت جائزه افضل ممثل
البراند الفريزر عن فيلم الحوت كما فاز
فيلم سي ان ان الوثائقين باني الذي يستكشف
مؤامره لاغتيال الناشط الروسي الم الفساد
والمرشحه الرئاسي السابق الكسنني بجائزه
اوسكار افضل فيلم وثائقي طويل في حفل
توزيع جوائز الاوسكار وتخلت جوائز
الاوسكار هذا العام عن السجاده الحمراء
لتحل مكانها لاول مره الشامبين كاربت التي
شهدت مرور المشاهير الى مسرح الحفل السنوي
الاضخم في عالم السينما ومنهم رهانه التي
بدت في مرحله متقدمه من الحمل كما ظهرت
لدجاجا باطلاله بسيطه خارج عن المالوف
خلال ادائها الغنائي في الحفل
[موسيقى]
على درك
خطوه وخطوه تمشي وقبل حفل الاوسكار بساعات
قليله اتجهت الانظار في العالم العربي الى
بيت الاردن الذي شهد عقد قران وزفاف ابنه
العاهل الاردنيه الاميره ايمان على السيد
جميل الكساندر تريموت في مراسم ابتسمت
بالاناقه والبساطه حضرها اميرات وامراء من
العائله الهاشميه وعدد من الضيوف ولي
العهد الاردني رافق شقيقته الى قاعه عقد
القران واستقبلها والدها في لقطات مؤثره
كما شهد على العقد شقيقها الاميران الحسين
وهاشم
وبزفه الاردنيه لفرقه معان استقبل
العروسان تحت الرماح المعقوده لحرس الشرف
في قاعه اخرى شهدت تقطيع قالب الحلوى
ومباركه العائله الهاشميه وتفعل الرواد
منصات التواصل في العالم العربي على نطاق
واسع مع مراسم الزفاف وليله الحناء التي
اقامتها الملكه رانيا للاميره ادمان
الاسبوع الماضي وفقا للتقاليد الاردنيه
ومن الاردن الى مصر حيث نشرت الفنانه
المصريه حلا شيحه صوره لها بدون حجاب عبر
حسابها الرسمي على انستجرام وذلك بعد ايام
من حذف كافه صورها الشخصيه والعائليه من
الحساب مع تنطباع بانفصالها عن الداعيه
معز مسعود الفنان المصريه التي اثارت
الكثير من الجدل خلال السنوات الماضيه
بتكرار التزامها بالحجاب وخلعه اعطت
انطباعا من خلال التعليقات على صورها
الاخيره انها في مرحله مراجعه للذات ومما
قالته تعليقا على الصور انهض ثم اسقط ثم
انهض واسقط مره اخرى حتى تجد نفسك الاصيله
وتذكر ان كل تلك النضالات قادتك الى فصل
جميل لم ياتي بعد
واخيرا لازال التفاعل مستمر على منصات
التواصل في العالم العربي مع الاعلانات
الرسميه لمسلسلات موسم العروض الرمضانيه
التي سينطلق الاسبوع المقبل ومنها المسلسل
المصري سر الباتع اول الاعمال التي يخرجها
خالد يوسف للتليفزيون المسلسل ماخوذ عن
قصه تحمل العنوان ذاته من مجموعه قصصيه
للاديب الراحل يوسف ادريس كما حقق الاعلان
الرسمي لمسلسل الزند ذئب العاصي من بطوله
النجم السوريه تيم حسن وادخار سامر برقاوي
تفاعلا كبيرا خاصه مع لهجه بطل العمل
يسترجعوا حقوقه
واثارت بعض بكسرات مسلسل مربى العز
للمخرجه رشا شربجي حاله من الدهشه على
منصات التواصل لصعوبه التعرف على الاشكال
الحقيقيه للممثلين